Zardo
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we're going to be
doing us a good old-fashioned ranking in
regards to parts one through eight of
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and just a
warning before we hop into things this
is going to be a super subjective video
here in the criteria for how I'll be
ranking the various parts is how much I
personally enjoyed them and of course I
will do my best to explain why that was
or in fact why I didn't enjoy them
because we all know that's bound to come
up at least once so I guess I should say
to anyone who's new to the channel that
I am quite new to the judge of us myself
and at the moment these are all my
initial impressions meaning that this
ranking could very easily change upon
reflection later in life after having
spent more time digesting series it is
another fun thing
due to the extreme difference between
pots with radically shifting genres that
appeal to different people depending on
what it is they like it is highly
unlikely that my pot ranking will be the
same as yours
well perhaps anybody's so please do feel
free to share your individuality by
leaving your personal preferences in the
comments below but with that out of the
way let's begin welcome to an arbitrary
new world review ranking of every Jojo
pot number 8 phantom blood my feelings
regarding pot 1 have not changed one bit
with the greater context of everything
else in fact in comparison to every
other part phantom blood continues to be
lacking and I think I said this in my
initial thoughts on it but it's not a
bad story by any means especially
considering the time period that it was
made in how phantom blood is I guess
painfully standed there's nothing that
truly elevates it into a memorable
experience everything about it is just
kind of flat it features by far the most
boring Jojo in the story sorry Jonathan
but that is just your role in life who
has no real depth of character and
represents something of an octa as for
the villain do is admittedly much more
interesting with Jonathan but he is
still so pointlessly evil and not quite
cartoonish enough to fit the bill of
what I would call peak deer and as for
the genre I think that part 1 very much
fails as an action horror piece and the
primary power system involved in it
being come on was underwhelming and
uninteresting most of the time although
I should say that it would be far far
better implement it in part 2 and look
phantom blood is the reason why it took
me four tries to actually get into
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure it might only
be a handful of chapters and nine
episodes but it feels so sluggish and
pointless that the temptation to give up
is just too strong at least
statistically 75
of the time I do appreciate that it laid
down some much-needed story to give
other parts the richness of the world
they enjoy but on its own I honestly
never want to read or watch this part of
the story ever again
number seven stone ocean now while
there's only one ranking difference from
fountain blood I want to be clear stone
ocean is far far far and above it in
terms of almost literally every aspect
of storytelling it features a fun cast
with the Jojo that I quite enjoy and
some really intriguing stands as well as
a climactic conclusion the likes of
which still has yet to be equaled in the
franchise where stone Ocean loses me
quite a bit though is its setting which
is a stock standard boring prison
anything and I don't care how many
people say dude how are you supposed to
make a prison interesting because it can
be done and it has been done in a lot of
other series but the lack of an
interesting setting forces so much of
the narrative heavy lifting solely onto
the characters themselves and I do think
that they do their best it just lacks
that general support of the world and
that's not all though because stone
Ocean is just one of those things where
I really don't know how to feel about it
because at the eleventh hour we are
introduced to a universal restructuring
stand power that just puts a full stop
on the Jojo universe as we knew it and I
don't necessarily mind that at all in
fact I'm quite endlessly fascinated by
made in heaven but it's a rather grand
escalation that isn't in any way built
up to considering we spent about like
80% of the series fighting very minor
threats in a very cramped and boring
prison there were just a lot of things
that stone Ocean is missing pieces of
connective tissue that if in place could
have really made this one of the greater
Jojo parts in my opinion but it just
happened to fall a bit flat very sad
stuff number 6 Stardust Crusaders
now I feel like a lot of people are now
calling me a blasphemous heathen by
placing pot three so far down the list
but I would like to stop by saying that
Stardust Crusaders features what is
probably my favorite coal group of
characters because Joshua polnareff
Joseph kakuhen abdullah and the
magnificent iggy are all iconic in my
mind and having a series that does adopt
a pretty laid-back comical element with
their interactions was always good fun
to watch however and this is a big
however it just did not fit the tone of
what Stardust Crusaders was trying to do
as a set up this is the larger scale
Jojo story yet well we finally need to
deal with deal once and for all
this is quite literally a fate of the
world scenario at hand here and for most
of the part we spend
90% of our time getting caught in
seemingly unnecessary roadblocks like
fun arse ongoing battle with bathrooms
which while funny just felt like we were
moving so slowly and very rarely did
these encounters actually go on to serve
to develop any of our established
characters the formula was basically our
team arrived in whatever random town or
place they'd go to a stand user or to is
conveniently waiting for them there one
of the group notices something weird and
really really frustrating Lee decides
for no good reason never to tell anyone
about it
at which point shenanigan rien sues the
stand user is beaten and our characters
returned to the status quo to repeat
their mistakes all over again
never learning anything and there are of
course some exceptions to this but they
are more the exception that proves the
rule because that's how the majority of
the series felt to me and it's not so
bad when you finally come to the
understanding that you just need to sit
back and enjoy what plays out in front
of you rather than actively searching
for some kind of story or character
development and it does have one hell of
an ending with the final two battles
against Vanilla Ice and deer hitting
those feels really really hard so there
is plenty to love about Stardust
Crusaders I just feel like most of the
other parts took this formula and
implemented it a hell of a lot better
number five
Jojo Lian next up is the most recent
addition to the series and the only part
that is as of yet incomplete so it's
ranking here is not fair at all because
depending on how things conclude it
could quite easily rise or it could
quite easily fall but thus far Jojo Lian
has been a really fun journey that takes
full advantage of the entire heritage of
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure constructing an
intriguing alternate Joestar family tree
as well as bringing in some other
classically known names back into the
fray like one Yoshioka kira for example
and what Jojo Lian has going strongly
for it though is that it features
probably the most intriguing Jojo we've
ever had in my opinion and I do very
much enjoy the journey we're going on to
find out both who he used to be as well
as watch him discover who he is now and
when I put it like that yeah it does
sound like a bit of a wanker journey of
self-discovery but that is kind of what
it is and it does work very well within
the greater genre of mystery each of the
secondary characters are also
fascinating in their own right as well
except for you and overall part 8 just
feels so strong the only thing I could
really criticize it for is often feeling
like it lacks direction but at the same
time that's exactly what a mystery is
you don't get to know the destination
before you get there and as a result you
are forced to just sit back and enjoy
yourself which I very much did with Jojo
Leon
number four golden wind so here we have
a true jojo triumph golden wind is one
of those examples of taking the stardust
crusaders formula and perfecting it
making it feel like our characters were
making great amounts of progress while
simultaneously still keeping the stand
of the weak structure in addition to
that golden wind features an incredibly
solid group of protagonists with a
fantastic sense of brotherhood that
develops around them through all the
experiences they come to be subject to
and I'll single out booty arathi and
Mistah in particular as characters who
captivated me throughout golden wind but
what really impressed me was just how
fantastically Italy was used as a
backdrop for the story the dedication to
detail and the construction of every
frame is at the very least worthy of
being called a pure work of art and I
loved that the designs of each character
also reflect the nature of this ornate
and stunning landscape because the
costumes in particular of golden wind
are unique even for a jojo series and it
was a really cool change of aesthetic
the one detractor I do have is that I
felt like Jonah was one of the more
boring JoJo's who was constantly being
out shown by I don't know literally
every one and I got a lot of feedback in
my golden wind review stating that
Jonah's character arc is just a lot more
subtle than others and while I
appreciate that and I do take the
arguments you all made that still does
not make him interesting or believable
to me I'd still insist that he is a 15
year old deus ex machina who will make
the perfect choice in any given scenario
99% of the time yes he does make
mistakes those mistakes are another
exception that proves the rule and in
some cases those mistakes end up being
the best cause of action anyway so what
I will give Jonah is that he was cool as
was golden experience Requiem and the
whole idea of requiems in general which
I feel is criminally under explored in
the series going forward but what can
you do I guess
number three battle tendency in terms of
story alone I would call this the best
church apart by far battle tendency
exists in a priest ant world where our
key wasn't capable of just doing the
weekly villain thingy
and that actually forced him to
construct a story of what he know a
story which was fantastic and I really
wish that he would do that a lot more
because part two shows that he is
perfectly capable of doing sir even at
that early stage of the series battle
tendency also very effectively fixed the
issues I had with phantom blood because
you know how Jojo is now actually
interesting heavily flawed of course and
in need of some learning as well as
character growth but that's the great
part and the side characters were
equally as compelling in the
antagonists of The Pillowman what an
improvement on dear or at least mama was
cause was very generically evil as was
ac/dc and Santana I don't even remember
few had a personality at all but wamu is
the key here and I still find it insane
that some people despise Part two as
much as they do and the last time I said
this none of you stayed at the battle
tendency is like universally loved but
from everything I've experienced no it
most certainly is not
I've seen people call this by far the
worst part in giorgo and I'm just like
are you out of your mind
and actually you know what if you want
one of those people please please do
leave a comment explaining what you
don't like about battle tenancy because
I am legitimately curious but for now
part two is easily one of my fondest
memories of this entire saga number two
diamond is unbreakable so things just
don't get much more perfect than part
four because this is the sweet spot of
Jojo this is the part where everything
just makes sense and fits into place all
thanks to a very simple genre change
choosing to leave the realm of
action-adventure and adopting a slice of
life format and it's difficult to
express just how much this enhances our
key storytelling because the chilled
nature of part 4 allows all of the
smallest subtle details to shine like
taking the time to properly enjoy what
may have been considered almost to fill
a story in part 3 but here everything's
just a lot of fun and a lot of that
might be because the stakes aren't
incredibly high here even after the main
antagonist is introduced because in the
end he's just a serial killer Kira is
not some world ending superpower and
that also goes on to make him one of the
greatest villains in the series because
this guy just wants to live a quiet life
and keeps incremental e needing to
escalate his actions to do so which was
really fascinating to watch but the
slice of life genre also helps the
entire ensemble of part 4 because it
allows them to stay in the picture
rather than being defeated and then just
never showing up again which gives us
gems like Rohan and a crazy amount of
time to explore him and others as well
as providing an opportunity to explore
some of the weirdest and powers as well
which aren't necessarily designed for
pure combat because combat is not
necessarily the name of the game in part
4 and yeah Dimond is unbreakable just
has it all and it is in my opinion the
crowning achievement of the first church
of us however we still have yet to
examine number one
steel ball run so if part four was
changing the genre to suit our keys
favored model then part seven is what
happens when our key properly adapts his
model to the more standard Church of
action-adventure realm and the result is
what I would consider to easily be the
greatest part in the series steel ball
run in many ways benefits from being
allowed to be its own thing without
having to be tethered to all of the
established Jojo history and stuff and
so we can do things like you know enter
a horse race and search for the corpse
of Christ
whilst being pursued relentlessly by the
President of the United States of
America but still bull run stepped up
the Joe Joe game in every conceivable
way firstly by presenting an incredibly
unique setting as well as a clear goal
that we needed to work towards in
regards to winning the race but it was
like looking at the peak of the mountain
from sea level and through this
structure our key was able to very
smoothly implement stand battles that in
no way to track from the end goal or
from the characters who wielded them and
that remains easily my favorite aspect
of steel ball run in fact that stands
are a utility a side story really and
the main focus is always on the
characters very well written characters
as well with gyro zeppeli being a clear
standout but not too far ahead of an
impressively morally ambiguous Johnny
Joestar a very conflicting alternate
dear and mister Stars and Stripes
himself everything about steel ball run
just works and I would definitely call
it our keys magnum opus because as much
as I love aspects of every other part
steel ball run is lightning in a bottle
it's an incredibly rare find and I
greatly appreciate having gotten to read
it and as such it is definitely my
favorite part of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure and that pretty much does it
for my ranking of parts one through
eight of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produce in general then please
do consider donating to the new
worldview patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
plot this channel and incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
disco server where a wide array of
Shannara takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
own personal charger apart rankings this
has been the new old review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]